Her low freak bitches way.
Most people think that if you don't use it,
you're an like,
if you don't,
it will save.
You Do,
do something every day.
Like I had a friend who was a longshoreman and he worked with this guide that
would shoot heroin every day at lunch.
And that always freaked me out because the guy showed up for work everyday on
time.
He was a responsible guy,
he was married,
he had children and this guy would get heroin.
He would cop every morning.
He would go there and he would sit in his truck and he would shoot up and you
know,
whatever,
however long that lasts,
you know,
he gets an hour lunch break and they would come back and go to work.
And I would like every day he goes every day.
Like I did it every day.
Well,
you know,
I,
this past summer,
the past three months or so,
I,
I was in Geneva,
just got back in the states.
Um,
and I was working in a heroin clinic where they administer heroin every day,
seven days a week,
twice a day to people who meet criteria for heroin addiction.
And when I say day administer heroin,
I don't mean like small doses,
I mean doses that they'll up to like a gram a day,
a thousand milligrams a day,
a lot more than what people use here in the states typically.
And these people who are getting heroin every day,
a large percentage of them also go to work.
A large percentage of them have families and they're taking care of their
responsibilities.
They are,
this is their treatment and this is a treatment that works for them.
But their treatment include two daily doses of intravenous heroin,
seven days a week,
you know?
And,
and so like when I think about,
well one of the reasons I went there,
and I did this because of the way we think of heroin in this country,
we think of it as such as evil drug.
And that's just a American mythology.
And,
and that's just wrong.
And that's ignorance and,
but that's how many including drug experts in this country think of heroin.
But that's just,
we have all of this great technology,
but we're so ignorant when it comes to many of these drugs.
So heroin administered intravenously a daily basis is not,
it's not devastating.
No.
In fact,
some people would do better about having a daily doses,
a daily dose of heroin or another opiate.
Um,
no,
it's not devastating.
I didn't see even me.
I would go,
fuck man,
that's got to fuck you up.
Like taken heroin every day.
Yeah.
And it's,
it's,
it's been this whole journey.
Men,
since I saw you last time,
I've been all over the world and this whole journey to see what people do with
drugs or with drugs they're using and how they do it.
It's been so eye opening,
even for me,
someone who has spent their life studying drugs and I'm learning so much more
now.
And,
but the Switz experience of,
uh,
the Dutch also do this.
There are some parts of Germany that does this.
They have small programs in,
in the UK,
they had small program.
There are other countries,
but the Swiss by far have the biggest program and they've been the most
successful.
They've been doing this for more than 20 years now.
And he started doing this in response to,
um,
uh,
HIV concern.
People worried about folks getting HIV.
So they had to do something,
had to have clean needles,
we had to make sure that the drugs were pure.
Um,
so they're worried about death,
HIV,
all of those things.
And this was the rational response where they put it in a medical community
where people got treatment and,
and,
um,
along with their heroin and they have no plans of going back,
nor should they,
because it works.
The mind is such a motherfucker,
like if you could just get your mind to do what your heart wants to do,
life would be so much easier.
Like there are so many times I'm in the cage,
right.
And
I don't know if my brain knew what my heart was trying to say,
but that's what I wanted to do.
You know?
And it's so,
and then you
fuck,
I can't even put words on it,
you know,
it's crazy.
Do you do any mental training?
Do you do any meditating or any visualization?
Fucking high school Budweiser rather than talking about,
God dammit fucking fight is a fight,
but I probably maybe should,
I mean seminars,
but you're a,
because of your style and because of nick style,
you guys are both really well loved.
Like if something like that happened with you,
you could go do seminars and make a few grand every weekend.
Maybe.
Maybe not in Dublin.
I don't have to go anywhere.
Once you guys fought,
you could do it.
If you and Connor fought and duked it out,
had an epic contest,
then you could do it.
You know,
I'm just a big stick in the mud.
If you beat him a couple times decisively,
you'd have to beat them to where they have to just give in.
They'd have to say,
all right,
you had to beat him,
beat him.
But if you're fucking cut down to one 45 you had nailed it.
Torch him.
Fucking Connor exam.
Man,
I appreciate the fuck out of that guy.
That guy's doing.
He's getting eyes on the sport.
Yeah,
he met Ron.
He really pisses me up.
I feel like to tell him when he was in the fucking pressure,
but I wanted to rip him so bad.
Of course.
Wanted to kill my own bag.
You know what car you can blow me like a cup of hot soup.
You son of a bitch but low me on like a cup of hot soup.
How's that work?
You blow on a cup of hot soup.
Is that what it is?
Yeah.
Okay.
I don't,
but if he just blows you like that.
That's why it's confusing.
The vernacular is really odd.
Like blow jobs.
I don't understand why that
blow me like a cup of hot soup first time.
First Time.
There you go.
Yeah.
I've never heard that one before.
I've been around
the uphill
battle because the way it's being treated presently.
Um,
if you look,
the literature from 2012,
410,000 servicemen came back as veterans and,
um,
were diagnosed with PTSD.
Now a post traumatic stress disorder is usually perceived as being a
psychological,
um,
psychologically precipitated event where they witnessed something that was
horrifying to them.
A death of a friend,
loss of a limb or whatever the situation might have been to stimulate it.
And that immediately opened him up to simple treatment here,
take this packet of antidepressants and you'll get better.
Well,
they didn't get better so they didn't get better because they were having what's
called treatment resistant depression,
which now we find is due to hormonal deficiency.
If you look at the civilian population,
people with hormones with treatment resistant depression,
you check them out and they testosterone deficient or estrogen overdose or low
progesterone or low pregnenolone,
other chemicals that are in our brain.
And um,
these individuals have been the,
um,
the foundation of what I do in trying to find a simple way to replenish them.
What you have to do is test them and that's not being done.
It's so much easier just to hand a packet and say you have PTSD when the
majority of them are traumatic brain injury.
And um,
I was on Dr drew show with one of our patients who was a army corpsman and he
didn't have a single scratch on his body.
But within two years of leaving a separating from the service,
he started developing depression,
mood swings,
explosive personality.
He ends up coming into our program and we find out he has two and a half hormone
deficiencies,
and the pattern is indicative of having had head trauma.
Well,
it turned out he would walk behind Abramson tanks as they were discharging their
shells,
and he said,
man,
my body would shutter,
and it was around javelin missiles.
He was around repetitive gunfire.
He personally didn't have a scratch on him.
That's incredible.
That just the recoil,
just the Bucharest does the sonic boom,
the impact that that,
you know,
shocking.
His body can do that too,
right?
[inaudible].